the adviser to the ICC Chief prosecutor
is a man named Theodore meron 94 years
old Holocaust Survivor former adviser to
the Israeli foreign Ministry he advised
the ICC to ask for a restaurants but
according to dlas and Natasha tonight
and many of you he's an anti-mite too
theore miron's everyone is anti-Semitic
anyone that's objective in the news is
anti-Semitic everyone's
anti-semitic these are some of the
drinks in my fridge guys just some of
them sub that we drink along water and
many other things many fruits to pick
from many foods to eat from Subhan Allah
what about the people who are starving
in Gaza all around the world who do not
have food eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down our throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for the food
project guys and they are 100% donation
policy charity I know the brothers who
run the charity and I have full trust in
them brothers and sisters and dear
friends here is a video of Mei Hassan in
five separate occasion moments where he
absolutely owned and annihilated Douglas
Murray or gutless muray an absolute
islamophobe bigot who is hostile towards
Islam to such a level that's something
that is so transparent in front of him
that innocent people being massacred he
absolutely no care that's why Allah says
this in the Quran in Surah they were
persecuting and killing the Believers
for no other reason because they say
their hostility and hatred towards us
because of our belief in Allah here is
the first one inshah it was absolutely
epic it seemed to me though Subhan Allah
as if the the people who were attending
this debate were there planted because
it is impossible them be the mere facts
that M Hassan was saying these were
facts let's wish for our here is the
first moment when Douglas Mari got
annihilated by m Assan sources but I
cannot allow Gideon to get away with
what he just said as which was
unbelievable why he said Israel isn't a
democracy first of all just just I don't
know maybe have you ever been there yes
when a few years ago not recently I
didn't I didn't I don't get awards from
the president of Israel like you do so I
don't get to do
softball I didn't get invited
into let me finish my point you went to
Gaza right you said you went to Gaza how
come you went to Gaza when the world's
media is not allowed into Gaza they took
you into Gaza of all I'll explain I'll
explain but let me pick up my points so
there you go the first moment he
absolutely got own by m Hassan you saw
it for yourself brother and sisters that
he can easily go in and out that's why
so you know so what does gutas muray
resort to calling him naming him stuff
calling him names ham supporter can you
imagine Hammer supporter for stating
mere facts and here is the reaction of
me Hassan to that choice at the end of
but let me just deal with a few things
that dou said there were a few things
were said I mean it's it's amusing I
wasn't surprised at all I came to debate
in Toronto to debate Israel with two two
Defenders of the current government and
so gide and I correct me if I'm wrong
didn't call we could have done a long
list of your apologist for genocide and
war crimes and crimes against humanity
we didn't do that but we've been called
liars and Hamas supporters and I get it
neither of us talked about Hamas we
don't support Hamas this is not a debate
about Hamas I know Douglas wants to
redefine it as a debate about Hamas
great good for him because he can't
actually deal with the arguments we're
putting forward all the Jews who are
putting forward these arguments they're
all anti-semites remember I just want to
deal with one point very important here
Douglas is the great journalist in
Israel I love this cosplaying as a
journalist going into Gaza with the IDF
Douglas interviewed Benjamin Netanyahu
in January D did not you're very
bothered by katar and spunding Hamas
your bosses but well we talk about
bosses let's talk to this you're
literally paid I've I've interviewed
I've interviewed Qatari officials you
can go on YouTube and watch my
interviews with katari official and then
you can watch Douglas interview Benjamin
n where he asked him pearls like is
there another chapter left in the
Netanyahu biography that was the strong
question he didn't ask Benjamin
Netanyahu why did you work with Qatar to
fund Hamas all those years why did you
prop up Hamas all those years why
according to today's Israeli media did
you have thought that there was going to
be attack on your citizens and
completely allow that to happen Douglas
didn't ask any of those questions
instead he'd like to spray around Hamas
at the Muslim on the stage Douglas
referred to Hamza YF the first minister
of Scotland recently as the first
minister of Gaza Muslim guy and he said
he said quot come to England you said
quote he has infiltrated our system
given where a debate about anti-Semitism
I find it ironic that you are throwing
out some of the most bigoted dual
loyalty tropes known to man referring to
a BN so you can see clearly that godas
Murray is somebody who's an absolute
Islam for bigot for him to call that to
Hamza the the the Prime Minister um in
Scotland you can see that he has a clear
hatred he he doesn't believe in
democracy in no way sh do you really
believe Godless Murray would be okay if
the majority of the votes were by
Muslims 51 52% and we wanted the Sharia
to run the UK like wanted to law the the
Sharia law to be the law of the land no
they don't believe in democracy it's a
big fat lie here is the next CLI where
he gets owned very briefly because I got
a question for Douglas very briefly I'll
be as brief as everyone else uh the the
the proposition have sprayed around the
word lie and liar so let's return the
compliment Natasha lied when she talked
about Ana and terrorism the UN set up an
independent inquiry asked the Israelis
for evidence I know you don't want to
hear
this the Israelis the they asked the
Israelis she's parting propaganda for
the isra isra government was just one
second they are booing him for stating a
mere fact he's stating a fact and he's
getting boed those that that crowd was
planted I don't care what anybody says
government was asked to give evidence
they refus to give their evidence every
Western government including your own
Canada's has restarted funding because
they looked at the evidence and didn't
see it that's great I get it I get it I
get it but but as Douglas mod have once
said facts don't care about your
feelings uh to come back to the other
point of life Douglas says the war would
end if Hamas gave back the hostages
complete lie the Israel said even if the
hostages come back we carry on the war
in fact I interviewed Abraham mun's
nephew ABR M's a 79-year-old Israel
hostage right now poor guy tragic 79y
old in captivity should be freed of
course had to have his birthday in
captivity his nephew says that every
time he goes on the streets Ben's police
beat him they beat him and arrest him
they're arresting hostage members fames
hostage family members and they're
coming on and saying why are we being
used as props by people who support the
war he doesn't support the war he wants
a deal Israeli family members are going
on the streets and being tear gassed and
water kind whatever beaten by the police
because they want to deal and they want
an end to the war that Douglas and zash
are so proudly support they keep telling
us about the horrors of October the 7th
I agree this side shares the revoltion
against the horrors of October the 7th
but we also share revoltion against the
horrors that came since October 7th we
don't support those Horrors I'm opposed
to the war crimes that happened on
October the 7th and the war crimes have
happened since October the 7th Douglas
no I got a finish Point I've got a
finish Point Douglas
here Douglas the week after October the
7th came out in The Spectator and
advocated for the ethnic cleansing of
Gaza which is a crime against humanity
under the Rome statute he said now is
not true you said now is a good time to
do it everyone can read the Peace of
other than M there you go he was
outright to perpetrate he was out right
calling that for a ethnic cleansing and
now he's oh no I didn't mean it like
this Etc you can see the hatred in his
eyes for someone to defend such an
apartheid regime that is causing
Massacre absolute ethnic cleansing
genocide you can clearly see if he had
the Powers himself he'd be doing exactly
what those scum dirt back idea soldiers
that are getting liquified which makes
me sleep at night better one by one he
would be doing exactly the same thing so
now Douglas Murray has a meltdown why
because all those Jewish protesters all
those Jewish students and non-jewish
students who are at the compasses here
is what he had to say about them this is
the reason why they are doing what
they're doing you know they're Jewish
they're Jewish but they're self-hating
Jews they're anti-semitic Jews implant
or trying to implant over the world's
most complex region and they think in
doing so that they're being good guys
and what they don't realize is that if
they got what they wanted they'd have
finished the work of ad
I know something you thought a lot about
too Douglas was telling us all about the
importance of Journalism going on the
ground while Douglas was getting awards
from the president of Israel we were
actually reporting my news organizations
ATO from those campuses with Jewish
students in fact the most R piece on our
site is from a student called Jonathan
Ben manakum who is at Columbia and
reported from inside the encampment
where they were having a Seda where he
was protesting war crimes in Gaza which
I know the other side thinks they're
onor war crimes everything we just
imagine the last eight months um what
you have to tackle tonight I'm glad we
brought up college coach campus because
again if this ridiculous sweeping motion
Douglas says complexity we are the side
of complexity we're not the one saying
anism across the board is anti-Semitism
you have to deal with the fact that
college protests are dispropor there are
disproportionate number of Jews in these
protests they're all brainwashed they're
all idiots they're all
self-pics of Columbia University who are
Jewish have come out to defend the
protest Analise orle is a 65-year-old
former chair of jewy studies at
Dartmouth she was beaten on camera by
police while she was protesting against
the war in Gaza apparently Douglas an
atheist says that she's an anti-semite
that's the debate that's what we've got
to today where the former chair of
Jewish studies at Dartmouth an anti-mite
while Douglas is the champion of the
Jewish people I find it bizarre and I'm
glad we've brought up College protest
because it's the number one evidence
right now in our discourse that actually
a lot of young Jewish people and by the
way this whole argument why didn't you
protest Sudan why didn't you protest
Syria last time I checked the United
States Congress does not fund Bashar Al
Assad or the rsf militias in Sudan so
stop with this lazy whataboutism that
gives you that gives you fund your
friends in tran the US Congress funds
Tran and now last but not least Douglas
muray comes with the accusation that
America is actually funding or
supporting Iran you can't make this
stuff up he's lost a plot here's the
last moment you know very well Biden's
package for Tran what you don't know
about it us funds Iran okay you got me
there dougas by the way by the way since
Biden de since Biden decided to bring
Iran back into jcpoa they are no longer
in under the sanctions that they were
and they've been into the fallo they end
up with International fing America
funding Iran like it funds Israel this
is absurd by the way just on fact check
uh Natasha gave us a lecture about she's
the lawyer on stage that's true you are
the lawyer on stage but literally the
chief prosecutor at the international
criminal court has asked for arrest
warrants and you're booing again again I
know you don't like it but by the way by
the way the adviser to the ICC Chief
prosecutor a man named Theodore meron 94
years old Holocaust Survivor former
adviser to the Israeli foreign Ministry
he advised the ICC to ask for
restaurants but according to dlas and
Natasia tonight and many of you he's an
anti-site too theor miron's let's just
keep the list you can't make this stuff
up guys yeah a previous Holocaust
Survivor advised the judges to go ahead
and give the arrest warrant he is an
anti-semite everyone is anti-Semitic
anyone that's objective in the news is
anti-Semitic every's antisemitic it's
like a badge of honor now it's like
people are carrying like it's
unbelievable they have used the word so
much that they are actually doing a
disservice to actual anti-Semitism
Zionism will end that was the five key
amazing moments M Hassan absolutely
annihilated Douglas Murray and on my
next video I'm going to be talking about
Jordan Peterson the absolute scum dirt
back intellectual fraud who is attacking
M Hassan for what that's all I have to
say brother sisters may Allah bless you
guys hope you guys enjoyed this as much
as I did may Allah subhana T Aid brother
massan against talking against
oppression against these individuals and
may Allah subh guide us and guide him
and all of us inum